hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play to nibbler sleep now
we found the wifey she is in a Cell and
I just went down a this looks like a
little song song she sounded ha ha get
on this place maybe I should just
believe and save myself uh no how about
not you gotta be good man good dude your
family is there nothing in here at all
like totes nothing be a douche
there's no how I [ __ ]
Oh what is that what the [ __ ] was that
what is that
open close ah right let's see what is
that I've never seen that before
Oh get you [ __ ] door I swear there we
go
I knew this was a suspiciously long
hallway now save your wife for children
I save my wife wait yes stand right by
the dynamite as it goes off the city
collapse on top of him you did not
survive I say goodbye to my children and
after done I decided to in France
senators take nothing more than a very
Wow
[Music]
yeah
that's it that's the end guys man Boris
Studios great job at that ending was a
little you don't have to choose to save
yourself your wife or your children
guess they make it explicitly check out
this mod try of here
hell yeah awesome check out his youtube
channel yeah maybe I don't know
[Music]
that was one of the best and for the
ending will be best and these custom
stories
neither mod have ever played the patient
great
you kind of got predictable right the in
there but
oh I know that but either way great
great great I've never been so scared in
a lot of a lot of mine a lot of my stuff
that I do so this is fantastic I am I'm
quad this guy's ever I was hoping it was
going to go on for the isn't so good but
he could only do so much I mean the
cryosphere modulus like
league of its own in terms of length and
stuff like that so that was good for it
[Music]
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna go back
and keep playing since there's only like
four minutes and I'm gonna I'm gonna
keep going go back I don't know where my
save is though if I just hit continue
it'll get me closest so I'm gonna go
back just so that you guys can see the
other endings I've got plenty of time so
I might as well so let's see what
happens when you save the kitties
yes it's me yeah lady I know that you
fear yes it's me oh god I don't want to
talk to you I'm gonna go find something
the kid okay gotta go if I definitely
get you out of here
let's go finally to get you out of here
Oh a long hallway again
go to this hallway reminds me of your
mom sorry there's only one now it's a
starting line maybe there and on your
market it should just go oh no it's the
darkest this is also kind of weird maybe
they just wanted to get a cheese scene
into the end here but you know the
darkness
you know that hasn't been in the game at
all the floor I mean nothing in this
game
so anyway I'm not worried about that
it's not going to
for me monster I didn't close that door
oh no it's gonna happen let's see let's
save the kitties let's save the kitties
cuz they deserved I was so you get to
live in now it's goodbye to my wife love
to dunt you together we moved to America
[Music]
that's sad
maybe there is some way to save all of
them like I'm not like yeah maybe maybe
there is maybe I could figure something
out something to do some some oh well
some oh something that was the ID the
wife that was the kids let's go see
super-secret save everyone object oh god
stop talking lady who's there dear
this latter thing are you oh it's so
ugly
okay what's this I can move that nothing
okay
let's try it one more thing I don't see
anything else maybe when I get in here
can I look around a bit I don't know I
don't know let's just do this one last
thing so I can see what the selfish
option is like for you guys the door go
maybe there was never a door there and
I'm going crazy I'm not crazy right
okay don't know if you guys can hear
that
it's not a dog die there's only one hey
wait we waiting waiting waiting eat that
waiting's please wait and save myself
ere we go oh no it's the de darkness
[Music]
and practically boring now
oh it crashed the door
I didn't even bother
oh what's that another Gorgon
Dorgan sounds like an alien
it's okay let's see see okay
I thought maybe okay not that why was a
wait why was a foot what is up there oh
no that's not where I fell
okay that's nothing mmm I don't know
I dunno okay let's just save myself
quick what I just left
but I guess it doesn't matter yeah okay
you travel to you
okay okay oh I'm acting but anyway all
right I don't know if there is a save
every one ending maybe there's not some
game makers don't like that sort of
stuff
something games like this squeeze your
morals make you make a choice anyway
other than that fantastic
custom mod fantastic mantra music you
don't have any to get it if you have
amnesia get this because it's amazing
it's awesome don't find it and thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in next video bye
bye